depuis vendredi soir nombre d'hommes
politiques en Corse et sur le continent
ont évoqué à propos de cette assassinat
l'ombre de la mafia le grand mot est
lâché mais il faut rester très prudent
car si effectivement la Corse connaît
une dérive Massieux mafieuse depuis
plusieurs années la situation dans l'île
n'a encore et c'est heureux rien à voir
avec ce qui se passe en Sicile même si
le risque d'une semblable situation
n'est pas à écarter Hervé
Palerme affiche le deuil drapeau retenu
geste solidaire adressé à la Corse ici
l'on sait ce que mafia veut dire
Ajaccio la mafia on en parle aussi dans
cette cité bouleversée par la mort de
son préfet on en parle même comme une
piste possible pour expliquer son
assassinat c'est l'occasion de mettre un
terme à cette dérive dont les arrières
plans
ce n'est mafieux
ne sont que trop apparent question
l'intégrité du préfet était-elle devenue
une gêne pour ses arrières plans
semi-mafieux sur le territoire le
représentant de l'État avait exercé son
autorité ici en particulier
un cadre superbe une affaire à saisir
l'armée vend son patrimoine ainsi
s'étend sur une superficie de 35 mm
carré et déjà s'avance le projet de
construire un hôtel et un casino pas
question d'iracle d'Erignac le haut
fonctionnaire est soupçonneux l'argent
qui se cache derrière le projet semble
fort douteux blocage de la vente aux
enchères au grand dames de l'auteur du
projet qui n'est pas au bout de ses
peines un an plus tard le différence se
déplace vers Ajaccio c'est au tour du
casino de se voir refuser son plan de
développement voilà trop de machines à
sous à deux pas d'un établissement
scolaire dira le préfet décidément après
le refus de l'achat de la caserne
l'homme du casino c'est le même petit
para local était dans le collimateur de
la préfecture un autre paradis Corse
avait attiré les convoitises les îles
lavazzi et Cavalo Cavallo résidence pour
milliardaire souvent plastique et
miraculeusement épargnés ensuite contre
rétribution un lieu de l'imbrication
entre mouvance nationaliste et mafia
selon le journal Le Monde un rapport de
la Direction de la protection et la
sécurité de la défense a d'ailleurs mis
en lumière le rôle d'un homme lié à la
mafia italienne un rôle actif dans
plusieurs de ses projets immobiliers
dans les années 83 85 un policier avait
évoqué et dérive mafieuses de l'île
à l'époque déjà il fallait pas trop en
parler parce que vraiment dans le
mouvement nationaliste on ne voulait pas
l'admettre et c'est peut-être été une
cause d'ailleurs essentielle des
divergences par la suite et des sessions
l'argent du raquette des trafices en
tout genre de détournement de l'argent
public la mafia sicilienne s'en est fait
une spécialité mais à une toute autre
échelle 40 000 hommes constitueraient
les troubles de la mafia point financier
230 milliards de francs l'équivalent de
l'affirme Fiat et quand on parle aux
spécialistes d'une association possible
avec la Corse les graines selon moi les
grandes associations mafieuses
italiennes ne se sont jamais associés au
corses écorce le préfet Reignac n'aurait
donc contrecarré ce qui n'est encore
qu'une dérive mafieuse la clé de son
assassinat est-elle recherchée sur cette
piste en tout cas cette dérive constitue
maintenant une cible claire pour l'État